يزداد إفراغ ثلاجة هانا كل
شهر ، حيث يعيش بائع الفاكهة والخضروات في الشوارع
على الأجور اليومية ، مما
يدفعه التضخم المتزايد إلى
تقليص كل
شيء آخر قطع الطعام
منذ أن قاموا بتعويم الجنيه ،
وزاد سعر الدولار من أسعار الفاكهة
، وأصبح من الصعب على الناس تحمل تكاليفها.
أكل الفاكهة
اعتاد بعض الناس على شراء خمسة أو عشرة
كيلوغرامات من الفاكهة الآن يمكنهم شراء
كيلوغرام واحد أو كيلوغرامين على الأكثر
، ويستغرق الأمر الآن ما يصل إلى أربعة أيام لبيع
ما يمكن أن يتم بيعه عادة في
أسرة مصرية واحدة من جميع مستويات الدخل
يشهدون قوتهم الشرائية  تتآكل
بسرعة مع لدغة التضخم ،
يؤدي الجنيه المصري إلى انخفاض
التضخم إلى 14.7 في المائة من 5 العام الماضي
الآن في محاولة لحماية
احتياطيات النقد الأجنبي المستنفدة
ولحماية قيود العملة على الواردات
مما يؤدي إلى ارتفاع الأسعار
ونقص جميع أنواع المنتجات التي
أشعر بها  كما لو كنا في وضع البقاء على قيد الحياة
وأصبح الأمر مخيفًا بعض الشيء
، فقد أصبح كل شيء كان في متناول الجميع
أقل و  مصر الأقل تكلفة هي
أضرار جانبية في غزو روسيا
لأوكرانيا اعتمادًا على 80 في المائة من
قمحها من هذين البلدين ، مما
يضاعف من الخسارة في العرض
تضاعف أسعار الحبوب العالمية منذ
فبراير
70 مليون مصري يعتمدون على
الخبز المدعم الذي يمثل 70 في المائة من
السكان.
تعمل على زيادة
الإنتاج المحلي للحبوب ،
يجب أن نعلم جميعًا أن خطورة
الأزمة ليست في مصر فقط ، ولكن الديون المصرية في جميع
أنحاء العالم
قد قفزت إلى مستويات غير مستدامة
مثل الأسواق الناشئة الأخرى ،
خسرت مصر مليارات الدولارات هذا العام حيث
سعى المستثمرون للحصول على أصول أكثر أمانًا
ضخت دول الخليج
قروضًا واستثمارات بمليارات الدولارات لدعم
الاقتصاد ، وعرضت الحكومة أسهمًا في
سبعة من موانئها الرئيسية وأصول أخرى تابعة للدولة
في محاولة لجذب مستثمري لعبة الجولف ،
يبدو الأمر وكأنه خلق وحوش جديدة
في وقت صعب للغاية
تحتاج فيه الحكومة إلى الكثير.  من
عائدات النقد الأجنبي لكي أتمكن من
تمويل
خدمة ديونها
أنا لست كذلك  قلقة من انهيار
الاقتصاد المصري ، فأنا قلق من
انهيار المزيد من الناس
تحت خط الفقر ،
وتوقعًا للاضطرابات الاجتماعية
، بدأت الحكومة
حوارًا وطنيًا مع المعارضة ،
وهو تغيير طفيف في المسار من سنوات من
القمع الوحشي لأدنى تلميح.
من أصل
حنا يعتمد على برنامج الدعم الحكومي
للأغذية الأساسية والمساعدات النقدية التي
يمكننا الاستغناء عنها دون تناول اللحوم وشرائها
مرة واحدة في الشهر ،
وقد نشتري الدجاج مرتين أو ثلاث مرات في
الشهر على عكس ما كان عليه الحال من قبل
كنا نشتري هذه مرة أو مرتين في
الأسبوع
الآن  لا يمكننا ذلك لأن دخلي منخفض
خوفًا من أن تكون هذه التضحيات
مجرد بداية لما يمكن أن يكون أزمة طويلة الأمد
ليني جاكوس سي إن إن